استثمار الامريكي مورستانلي من ثلاثه
مخاطر تمويليه قال انها قد تضرب الاقتصاد
المصري بشده ابرزها احتمال خفض تصنيف مصر
الائتمانيين للمره الثانيه هذا العام كما
رجح تخفيض السعر صرف الجنيه المصري من
جديد يتزامن هذا مع ابرام صندوق النقد
العربي اتفاقا لتقديم قردا جديد لمصر
واصدار اكبر بنكين حكوميين مصريين شهاده
ادخار دولاريا
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم كان ذاك خبر حلقتنا لنا في نقاشه
ثلاثه مسارات الى اي حد يعكس تحذير بنك
الاستثمار الامريكي الشهير الحاله
الاقتصاديه في مصر وكيف سينعكس تحذيره على
نظره المستثمرين الخارجيين للاقتصاد
المصري
كذلك ما امكانيه اقدام القاهره على تعديل
سعر الجنيه من جديد في ظل الضغوط المترتبه
على رغبتها في الحصول على قروض خارجيه
اضافيه وجذب مستثمرين اجانب الاقتصادها
وما مدى نجاعه الاجراءات التي اتخذتها
الحكومه المصريه للتعامل مع تحدياتها
الاقتصاديه وعلى اي نحو ستنعكس هذه
الاجراءات على المواطن المصري
[موسيقى]
بعد نحوي خمسه اشهر من تخفيض وكاله موديز
الدوليه للتصنيف الائتماني تصنيف مصر
الائتماني من درجه بي اثنين الى درجه بي
ثلاثه خرج واحد من اشهر بنوك الاستثمار
الامريكيه هو بنك مورجان ستانلي ليحذر مما
سماها ثلاثه مخاطر تمويليه كبيره قال انها
قد تضرب الاقتصاد المصري بشده خلال الفتره
القادمه البنك الذي رجح في تقريره الذي
نشره السبت ان تجري الحكومه المصريه
تعديلا جديدا على السعر صرف الجنيه مقابل
العملات الاجنبيه في ايلول سبتمبر او
تشرين الاول اكتب المقبلين توقع في ابرز
المخاطر التي حذر منها ان تقدم وكاله
موديز على خفض تصنيف مصر للمره الثانيه
خلال هذا العام وان يجري ذلك اواخر شهر
تموز يونيو الجاري او الاوائل اب اغسطس
المقبل وهو ما ستكون له تبعاته الاقتصاديه
على ملف الاستثمار الخارجي بحسب البنك
طبعا تحذير البنك الامريكي الشهير من
مصاعب منتظره للاقتصاد المصري تزامن مع
الاعلان عن صندوق النقد العربي لاتفاقيه
لتقديم قرض جديد لمصر بنحو
616 مليون دولار لتعزيز كفاءه القطاع
المالي والمصرفي المصري ايضا مع اصدار
اكبر بنكين حكوميين في مصر هما البنك
الاهلي وبنك مصر لشهادتي ادخار دولاريه
جديدتين وذلك في اطار محاولات الحكومه
المصريه للتعامل مع ازمه شح العملات
الاجنبيه في البلاد والعديد من المصاعب
الاقتصاديه الاخرى التي تواجهها مصر خلال
الفتره الاخيره
[موسيقى]
ولمناقشه هذا الموضوع معنا من القاهره
الدكتور عبد النبي عبد المطلب استاذ
الاقتصاد السياسي وخبير الاقتصاد الدولي
ومعنى من الدكتور مصطفى يوسف الباحث في
الاقتصاد السياسي اهلا بكما فيما وراء
الخبر ابدا معك دكتور عبد النبي عبد
المطلب اذا ثلاثه مخاطر تمويليه قد تضرب
الاقتصاد المصري بشده كيف تنظر انت الى
هذا التحذير القوي من بنك ستانلي موجن
يعني انا شخصيا هذا التحذير متوقع وتقليل
التصنيف الائتماني لمصر متوقع وصدور
تقارير سلبيه عن حاله الاقتصاد المصري
سواء حاليا او مستقبلا متوقع في ظل عدم
وجود مراجعه مع صندوق النقد الدولي او عدم
وضوح الرؤيه بشان الاتفاق مع صندوق النقد
الدولي سوف تتوالى التقارير السلبيه على
الاقتصاد المصري لكن انا شخصيا اعتقد ان
هناك جزء مضيء في تقرير بنك مورجان ستانلي
فيما سبق كان هناك توقعات ان تنخفض قيمه
الجنيه الى مستويات غير مسبوقه يعني كان
هناك توقعات بان يبلغ الدولار ما بين 45
وخمسين جنيه لكل دولار في خلال منتصف
اغسطس القادم الان تقرير البنك مورجان
ستانلي يتحدث عن تخفيضات لكنها ما دون
الاربعين جنيه وانا اعتقد ان هذه نقطه
مضيئه وكما جاء في التقرير يعني اعتقد ان
مصر عندما بدات في طرح شهادات الدولاريه
مرتفعه العائد قد تج منها يعني عوائد
تتراوح ما بين اثنين الى خمسه مليار دولار
واعتقد ايضا ان هذا الاجراء قد يشجع بعض
الاشقاء في دول الخليج وانا هنا اتحدث عن
افراد وليس اتحدث عن الحكومات وهو جزء
كبير منهم يرغب في مساعده الاقتصاد المصري
فانا اعتقد انه سوف يكون هناك اقبال على
الاكتتاب في مثل هذه الشهادات وهذا سوف
يوفر سيوله الى حد ما للاقتصاد المصري
والحكومه المصريه تمكنها من عدم الانجرار
وراء طلبات الصندوق بتخفيض او بتعويم
الجنيه بشكل كبير قبل ان يعني نتحدث
باسهاب عن التداعيات دعونا اولا نحاول ان
نفهم هذا التحذير من بنك دكتور مصطفى يوسف
هل توافق الدكتور عبد النبي فيما يتعلق
بالمؤشرات التي ادت
لهذه التحذيرات التي اطلقها
يعني كما تفضل الضيف الكريم من القاهره
يعني كان متوقعا كثير من يعني المؤشرات
السلبيه والتقارير التي يعني تحذر
بشده وخرجت من عده مراكز ابحاث وبنوك
ومؤسسات دوليه بان الاقتصاد المصري يسير
من سيء الى اسوا يعني ان يصل خلال
الجمهوريه الجديده يعني عشر سنوات منذ
يوليو 2013 ليوليو 2023 سعر صرف الجنيه
على الدولار من سته جنيه 35 قرش الى قرابه
الاربعين جنيه هذا امر خطير ان يزداد
معدلات الفقر ويزداد معدلات التضخم اثر
التقرير دبلوم الذي يقول ان مصر ثالث اعلى
دوله في العالم يزداد فيها اسعار الغذاء
خلال اقل من عام باكثر من 66% ويحذر زي
ستيفانكي من جونز هوب بان تضخم في مصر
تجاوز ال 110% على مقياس قام به في جامعه
الشهيره فنحن امام مشكله حقيقيه يعني
محاوله
الاشقاء سواء كانوا افرادا او شركات خاصه
لمساعده الاقتصاد المصري كما قالت يعني
مديره الصندوق النقد الدولي فنحن كمان يضع
ماء في وعاء مسطول هناك حلول حقيقيه جذريه
ينبغي ان تكون موجوده الا وهي يعني
الشفافيه سياده القانون حينما تكون
اسمح لي دكتور مصطفى هنا فيما لو فعلا
خفض التصريف الائتماني للمره الثانيه هذا
العام ما الذي تتوقع ان يحدث
يعني اولا ستزداد كلفه الاقتراض سيحكم
المستثمرين الدوليين سواء كانوا في
الاموال الساخنه او من ياتي لكي يقوم
باستثمار استثمارات مباشره يعني يعني
سيزداد وضع الاقتصاد المصري قتامه نحن
يعني لدينا موقف عدم وجود دراسات جدوى
التوسع في مشروعات كبيره جدا مشروعات
قوميه دون تخطيط مسبق دون دراسات هذا الذي
ادى للموقف الذي نحن فيه يعني يعني كان
لدينا تجارب تنمويه في المنطقه وتجارب
دوليه تجارب من البرازيل تجارب من
السنغافوره تجارب كذلك من المغرب الشقيق
ولكن فقط حتى يعني دكتور يعني مشاهدنا في
النهايه غير المتخصص ربما لديه بعض
التساؤل فيما يتعلق بزياده كلفه الاقتراض
كيف
يعني حينما تزداد المخاطر يعني يوجد ما
يسمى بتحليل العائد مع المخاطر حينما تكون
المخاطر اكثر حينما يتطلب المستثمر الذي
يقرض مصر مصر الان حينما يقربها على سبيل
المثال بالدولار بسبعه او ثمانيه في الميه
سيطلب عشره في الميه حينما يزداد التصنيف
الائتماني سوءا هذه المؤشرات التي تحدث
مصر يعني ينبغي ان الحكومه المصريه ان
تحسن من وضع التصنيف الائتماني ان تتسارع
خروج المؤسسه العسكريه من الاقتصاد يعني
حينما قامت الجمهوريه الجديده كانت تصاب
العسكري في مصر لا يتجاوز الربع الان
تجاوز طبقا للباحث الرئيسي في كارنيه
يعني يزيد
76% فالان يعني يعني ينبغي على الاقتصاد
المصري ان يتحول الى القصر
دكتور عبد النبي عبد المطلب الى اي حد
تتفق مع هذا الكلام خصوصا ان يعني مشاكل
والتحديات امام الحكومه المصريه سواء في
جذب الاستثمارات او التعامل مع الديون
كبيره
فالسؤال الذي يطرح نفسه ما الذي يمكن ان
تفعله القاهره هنا
يعني القاهره امام خيار وحيد يعني انا في
اعتقادي هي يعني دخلت في مفاوضات مع صندوق
النقد الدولي
التزمت بالمجموعه من التعهدات للصندوق وفي
مقابل هذه الالتزامات كان من المتوقع ان
يفرج صندوق النقد الدولي عن الجزء الثاني
من الشريحه الاولى من قرض الصندوق وكان
هناك توقعات ان يؤدي هذا الافراج الى
تشجيع
ما يسمى الشركاء الدوليين الاقتصاد المصري
على القدوم وزياده الاستثمارات الى مصر
وكان من المتوقع ان يصل حجم الاستثمارات
في نهايه يوليو الحالي الى 17 مليار دولار
لكن طبعا للاسف في الشديد لن تتمكن مصر من
الوفاء بالتزامتها وكان هناك يعني نوع من
التسويف ما بين اداره السياسات النقديه
المصريه وما بين صندوق النقد الدولي وكانت
النتيجه تاجيل المراجعات كان لدى الحكومه
المصريه امال بان تتمكن من اعاده جوله
المفاوضات التي تمت في عام
2016 عندما تقدم وعودا وفي مقابل هذه
الوعود تحصل على اموال لكن الواضح ان
اداره الصندوق هذه المره تريد افعالا
مقابل الاموال ما تفضل به الدكتور مصطفى
هي مؤشرات لا يستطيع احد ان ينكرها هناك
بالفعل سوء اداره للموارد الاقتصاديه هناك
غياب للشفافيه بالكامل يعني حتى الان سواء
المصريين او الشركاء الدوليين لا يعلمون
ما هي خطط الحكومه للتعامل مع كارد صندوق
النقد الدولي
اذا اتى سبتمبر ولم يتم وضع
تجديد الاتفاق مع صندوق النقد الدولي على
جدول اعمال مديريه التنفيذيين اعتقد انها
سوف تكون مشكله كبيره حتى لو تمكنت مصر من
حل ازمه انعدام السيوله الدوليه او توفير
العملات الصعبه بالشكل الذي والى الى
الافراج عن كل الواردات وتلبيه الاحتياجات
الداخليه ستبقى العقبه الكوده هي كيف سيتم
التعامل مع صندوق النقد الدولي والمؤساه
الدوليه ومن هنا انا في اعتقادي ان
الحكومه المصريه امامها خيار خيار وحيد ان
تجري المراجعه الاولى مع صندوق النقد
الدولي وتحقق جزء من هذه الالتزامات التي
التزمت بها ربما بعد ذلك في العام القادم
تستطيع مصر ان تصل الى اتفاق جديد مع
صندوق النقد الدولي لا يجبرها على التعويم
الكامل للجنيه او طرح شركات الجيش
سبتمبر فانه من المرجح او مع نهايه سبتمبر
او حتى في اكتوبر
ان تقدم القاهره على خفض العمله الجديده
هل
ان هذا هذا شيء محسوم يعني
ليس هناك اي مجال لعدم اتباع هذه الخطوه
لا لا يوجد مجال اخر لكن الفرق هنا يعني
انا شخصيا انا اعتقد انه لولا شهاده
دولاريه كان من المقرر ان يتم تخفيض قيمه
الجنيه بنسبه تتراوح ما بين عشرين الى 30%
بمنتصف اغسطس القادم يعني كنا نتحدث عن
دولار يساوي ما بين 45 الى 48 جنيه بعد
موضوع الشهادات الدولاريه انا اعتقد ان
التخفيض سوف يكون اقل حده ربما يبلغ
الجنيه من 35 الى 38 جنيه صحيح ان التبعات
سوف تكون غليظه على المواطن المصري وعلى
الاقتصاد المصري لكن يعني فرق من 48 الى
38 اعتقد ان المساله سوف تكون اقل قسوه
ولو انها سوف تظل قاسيه ندعو الله ان
يتحملها الاقتصاد المصري والمواطن المصري
طيب ما نوع المشاكل وهنا السؤال دكتور
مصطفى ما نوع المشاكل التي يمكن ان تترتب
فعلا على خفض قيمه العمله برايك
مبدئيا يعني العمله ستنخفض كما تفضل يعني
الضيف الكريم دكتور عبد النبي من القاهره
الى قرابه الاربعين من 38 الى 40 مع على
بدايه سبتمبر على الاكثر يعني وللاسف مصر
بدء الجمهوريه الجديده يعني لا تكتفي
ذاتيا من الغذاء بل نستورد اكثر من 70% من
الاغذيه
ويعني وسوء اداره ملف سد النهضه ادى يعني
انحصار وشحح كميه المياه الوارده مما ادى
لزياده الوردات الغذائيه فسيترتب على ذلك
غلاء شديد جدا تخيلي ان يعني الدولار الذي
سيكون سعر الرسمي قرابه الاربعين جنيه مع
استيراد 70% من الاغذيه ومعظم السلع
الوسيطه التي تستخدم في الصادرات المصريه
فنحن الان امام مشكله مركبه مشكله يعني
غلاء الدولار وتقليل معظم الواردات ثم
غلاء الاغذيه ويعني كما قلت ان مصر تعتبر
سادس اكبر دوله في العالم اثبت فيها اسعار
مع تضخم غير مسبوق يعني المشاكل التي تضرب
المواطن المصري يعني من الممكن ان يكون
هناك بارقه امل اذا يعني خرجت الحكومه
بمكاشفه واعتذار وزياده للشفافيه وبيع هذه
المشروعات القوميه التي لا جدول من وراءها
ما جدول وجود قطار كهربائي على سبيل
المثال مدد وجود العاصمه الاداريه الجديده
في يعني في بلد يعني اكثر من ثلثين سكان
طبقا للبنك الدولي حول خط الفقر اما تحت
خط الفقر او على خط الفقر نحن الان نريد
ان نستثمر في الانسان نتعلم التجربه
المغربيه التي تصدر الان سيارات للاتحاد
الاوروبي ب 11 مليار دولار بها اكبر مصنع
في العالم لانتاج البطاريات السيارات
الكهربائيه نستثمر في الانسان نحاول زياده
الصادرات نحاول تشغيل السوق الداخلي بدلا
من الانفاق على مشروعات بالطبع ابهاري لا
جدوى من ورائها هذا الذي سيشجع المستثمرين
الاجانب سواء من الشركاء الاقليين كما قال
صندوق النقد الدولي الدوله العربيه حينما
نراجع يعني تصريحات المسؤولين سواء وزير
الماليه السعودي او الجانب الاماراتي او
الجانب القطري
فيتحفظون ويريدون ان يشتروا الاصول بما
ينفع دولهم يعني انتهى عصر دعم بلا حدود
وبلا رقيبه بلا حسيب اي دوله الان في
العالم مع الازمه الماليه العالميه تريد
ان تستثمر يعني الان الجميع مسؤول امام
شعبه فنحن ينبغي على الحكومه ان تقوم ببيع
المشروعات غير ذات الجدول الاقتصاديه
والاستثمار في الصناعات الصغيره دعم
الصادرات
يتوجه بهذه النقاط التي اثرتها الى
الدكتور عبد النبي عبد المطلب ما امكانيه
تحقيق ذلك فعليا يعني لسته طويله من
المطالب التي تبدو جميله هكذا ولكن هل
فعلا يمكن ان تطبق على ارض الواقع بالنظر
لما يجري في مصر حاليا
يعني انا في اعتقادي ان كل شيء ممكن يعني
هو المطلوب هو استعاده ثقه المواطن المصري
اولا ثم استعاده ثقه رجال المال ورجال
الصناعه في الاقتصاد المصري المطلوب ان
يتم توفير التمويل وهذا يعني امر هين
للافراج عن الواردات الموجوده وخاصه
المستلزمات الانتاج والمواد الخام وما في
حكمهم من اجل ان تعود لصناعه والزراعه الى
العمل يعني هناك بعض المصانع التي اغلقت
لعدم توافر المواد الخام او عدم توافر قطع
الغيار نتيجه الاجراءات التي تم اتخاذها
لتقييد الواردات هذه امور يمكن بالتاكيد
حلها وحلها بسهوله يعني مصر بتمتلك
احتياطي نقدي في حدود 34 مليار دولار وهو
اعلى كثيرا من الاحتياطي النجدي النقدي
العالمي المطلوب تستطيع مصر ان تعمل او او
تستخدم جزء من هذا الاحتياطي في حدود من
خمسه الى عشره مليار دولار للافراغ عن كل
الواردات الموجوده في المواد
ان يكون
يعني هناك اجزاء كثيره جدا ربما ان لها
وجهه نظرها يعني تخشى الحكومه المصريه
انها في ظل مفاوضات مع صندوق النقد الدولي
وتنتظر مراجعه ان ينخفض الاحتياطي النقدي
القانوني عن الاحتياطي العالمي المقرر
قانونا فيتم تخفيض التصنيف الائتماني وهذا
امر يعني مؤكد لجمهوريه مصر العربيه وان
تكون هذه نقطه الضغط للمواسات الدوليه
للتاكيد على ان مصر ليست قويه بالشكل الذي
يجعلها تحافظ على الاحتياطي النقدي طبقا
للمعايير العالميه لكن هو يعني خيار
استراتيجي ممكن ان تلجا اليه مصر اذا كانت
ترفض ان تستجيب بالكامل لتوصيات صندوق
النقد الدولي وفي مقدمتها خطوره تعويم
الجنيه المصري تعويم الجنيه المصري في ظل
الظروف الحاليه سوف يمثل كارثه بكل
المقاييس لكن مصر لديها احتياطي نقدي ما
اهميه الاحتياطي النقدي ان لم يستخدم في
مثل هذه الظروف ايضا تشجيع رجال الاعمال
من خلال ايجاد اليه مشتركه لبث واعاده
الثقه بينهم يستطيع رجال الاعمال المساهمه
بالفعل في انعاش الاقتصاد المصري او ما
يسمى بحقن الاقتصاد المصري من خلال
استثمارات سواء بقى استثمارات محليه او
استثمارات مصريين موجودين في الخارج يعني
يجب ان يعلم الجميع ان المصريين الموجودين
في الخارج بيمثلوا ثروه وثروه كبيره جدا
للاقتصاد المصري عند وجود ثقه حقيقيه في
ان مصر لديها خطه شفافه وواضحه للتنميه
اعتقد انها سوف تتمكن من اكتساب جزء غير
قليل سواء من الاستثمارات المصريين
الموجودين في الداخل او حتى من
الاستثمارات المصريين الموجودين في الخارج
يعني هناك امور لك انها تحتاج الى جزء من
يعني الشجاعه والاقدام والشفافيه واستعاده
الثقه ما بين رجال المال ورجال الحكم
وايضا ان يكون هناك تاكيد على ان للمواطن
المصري دور في اتخاذ القرارات وتنفذها
وليس تحمل نتائجها وتبعتها فقط يعني ليس
من مقبول ان ترتفع الاسعار كل يوم ويكون
على المدن المصري الاحتمال والتحمل دون ان
يكون هناك رؤيه قريبه لانفراجه تمكنه من
حياه كريمه حقيقيه
والسؤال للدكتور مصطفى
يعني في ظل القرارات او الاختيارات التي
تختار القاهره اللجوء اليها كيف سينعكس
هذا على حياه المواطنه المصري العادي الذي
يعاني حاليا اقتصاديا
مبدئيا يعني الاحتياطي النقدي الموجود في
مصر اكتر من ثلاثه ارباع ودائعه خارجيه
وهذا امر مخيف تجدد هذه الودائع دعما من
الدول يعني الخليجيه حتى تظل مصر دوله
مستقره هذا الامر الاول الامر الاخر يعني
حينما ننظر الى تحويلات المصريين في
الخارج نجدها قلت بقرابه الثلث في ظل هذه
الازمه الاقتصاديه لفقدان الثقه ما بين
المصريين في الخارج والطريقه التي تدار
بها الدوله المصريه الخيارات الموجوده
امام الحكومه المصريه الان هو خيار وحيد
اكشفكير الاعتذار عن المشروعات الغير
مدروسه وبيع هذه المشروعات ما يعني ما هو
سبب الرئيسي الذي يجعل مصر تقوم ببناء
العلمين الجديده والعاصمه الجديده
والمونوريل والقطار الكهربائي هذه
المشروعات استنفذت يعني عشرات بل مئات
المليارات من الدولارات الامر الاخر يعني
التوسع في بناء محطات كهرباء يعني كما صرح
يعني الرئيس نفسه يعني بمبلغ يعني يقت
يعني 200 مليار دولار وبالرغم من ذلك
يعاني المصريين من انقطاع الكهرباء الامر
ينبغي نوع من المكاشفه والمصارحه
والاعتذار حتى يجتذب ثقه ثقه المصريين في
الخارج ثقه رجال الاعمال وليس رجال
الاعمال المحسومين على النظام وشقه وثقه
الشركاء يعني الاقليميين يعني هذه الدول
يعني الدول الخليجيه والمصريين في الخارج
ورجال الاعمال سيحترمون ما تقوم بالحكومه
المصريه حينما نجد اعتذارا حينما نجد بيعا
لبعض القصور التي بنيت والطائرات التي
اشتريت
والعاصمه والمدن الجديده التي بنيت
كل هذه ودمج يعني اهم شيء على الاطلاق دمج
الاقتصاد العسكري داخل المصدر العامه
للدوله ووضع الفوائد التي لدى المؤسسه
العسكريه تحت امره الوزن العامه للدوله
مما يؤدي الى انخفاض العجوزات ووجود فوائد
اموال تنعكس ايجابا على المواطن المصري
وتخفض من اسعار السلع وتقلل من الاعباء
الشديده التي تتحملها للمواطن المصري
حينما انظر الى مؤشرات التعليم الصحه يعني
الصناعات الصغيره كافه المؤشرات للاسف في
انهيار منذ قيام الجمهوريه الجديده لغياب
الشفافيه وغياب يعني المشاركه المجتمعيه
دكتور عبد النبي عبد المطلب الشفافيه
والاعتذار هل هي كافيه فعلا لاعاده الثقه
سواء في الداخل او في الخارج وما نوع
الاجراءات التي يمكن فعلا ان تتبع الحكومه
حاليا للتخفيف على المواطنه المصري
يعني هو الشفافيه ووجود خطه واضحه
بالتاكيد سوف تساعد الاستثمار المستثمرين
سواء في الداخل وفي الخارج على زياده
الاستثمارته لكن بشرط ان يكون هناك بالفعل
برنامج حقيقي ونوايا حقيقيه من اجل اصلاح
حقيقي يعني حتى مع صندوق النقد الدولي
المشكله ان الحكومه كانت تعتقد ان الوعود
سوف تكفي للحصول على الاموال اما
الاجراءات المطلوبه من اجل تخفيفها على
المواطنين فانا اعتقد انه على الدوله ان
توفر على الاقل السلع الاساسيه الرئيسيه
باسعار مناسبه سواء كان من خلال المنظومه
التموينيه او من خلال تخفيض ضريبه القيمه
المضافه او الغائها على السلع الغذائيه
بدايه من الحبوب ونعيدا بالزيوت التي يعني
وصلت اسعارها الى اسعار كبيره جدا ايضا
اعتقد ان على الدوله ان تراجع جزء من
سياساتها في وقف في قرارات وقف النشاط
الاقتصادي مثل البناء والتعمير ويعني وان
يكون هناك تيسير في الحصول على رخص للبناء
والتعمير لان ذلك سوف يعيد عدد كبير جدا
من العماله الموسميه للعمل يعني العماله
الموسميه في مصر بتمثل جزء كبير جدا
بنتحدث عن ما يزيد عن 19 مليون مواطن مصري
بعلون يعني على الاقل اكثر من 40 مليون
اسره في ظل هذه الظروف في ظل قرارات مكبره
للنشاط الاقتصادي وقرارات مقبله لانسياب
حركه التجاره الخارجيه بما فيها
الواردات
المواد الخام ومستلزمات الانتاج وقطع
الغيار هذا سوف يؤثر بشكل كبير جدا على
الزراعه اساسا والصناعه بشكل اساسي لان
انا الالات بتستخدم في الزراعه وفي
الصناعه شكرا جزيلا لك دكتور عبد النبي
عبد المطلب استاذ الاقتصاد السياسي وخبير
الاقتصاد الدولي من القاهره وشكرا جزيلا
للدكتور مصطفى يوسف الباحث في الاقتصاد
السياسي من
وشكرا لكم مشاهدينا الكرام على متابعه هذه
الحلقه من برنامج الخبر في
[موسيقى]